All right.
Ron Schilling, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
Nice to be here.
Great to have you.
You know, you have such a wealth
of experience over 35 years
in the medical imaging technology sector.
You've led incredible achievements
within Toshiba Medical
and General Electric Medical.
Masters at Princeton,
a PhD back in Polytechnic,
now it's NYU.
Ron, give me a brief rundown over
of what you've done in this
medical devices technology industry
and I'd love to spend the next 19 minutes
or so learning myself as much as I can
over this industry.
OK, well I started out
at General Electric in the medical field
after having coming
coming out of the semiconductor field.
And GE wanted me for semiconductors
but we didn't make a go of that
because there was a
a very bad market condition in '74.
In '76, they asked me again
"How about the CAT scanner?"
And I said,
"Oh my goodness, what is that?"
I asked friends of mine.
They said,
"Very high risk but very high reward
if it does work properly."
And sure enough, CT became
an incredible reward for all.
The thing about it at General Electric was
that the general manager of the business
that I was in, the overall medical business,
had an opportunity to become chairman
of the company
if the CT business did well.
That was Jack Welch,
a very famous name today.
Unfortunately, we lost him about
eight months ago.
And I came in there
and took on the service,
the marketing organization
for the GE CT program
and I went and spoke to customers
'cause having come
from the semiconductor industry,
you always got out there
to talk to customers.
So, I have a question.
Ron, just paint me a picture.
What year are we?
And I mean, is CT a common thing
around the US at that point?
No, no, no, no.
That was 1976.
CT, was just getting started.
So, and today it's practically
at every hospital, right?
Everywhere you go.
Okay. So, you're really a pioneer
in introducing the CT
to the American market, right?
Right.
So in getting out there
and talking to customers,
they told me that they were very concerned
because this is a new device for them.
Right.
They were used to basic X-ray.
And but what they explained to me was that
CT is about systems,
applications and service,
not just the technology.
So to me, the whole game
was all about quality.
Quality of getting our systems to work
the very best of anyone else's system.
Right.
We may not have had
the very best technology,
but because we had
a large organization and x-ray,
we had the best performance
out there in the field.
And we won very big.
We were number one in the United States.
A lot of companies came
into the marketplace.
They went out of the market
leaving the standard
companies working with us.
What was the deciding factor
in helping GE when, aside of course,
you leading the endeavor.
But what were the deciding factors
that made you come on top
versus your competitors
in retrospect?
It was the quality and the images.
It was purely the quality
of the product?
Absolutely.
And we worked very closely with customers.
That was another thing.
We called it the clinical technical tie.
That is, there's a clinical need
and we understand the customers' need
almost as well as they did
because we spoke to many customers.
And clinical technical timings
bring the technology
to the customer situation
and create the right
solution for the right job.
Okay.
So, we had the best brain imaging.
We had the best body imaging.
We had the best knee imaging.
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
We were very applications oriented.
Right.
And that was a very very
important aspect of that,
something that I came away with
from the semiconductor industry.
Wow.
Then as I moved up
into GE's medical organization,
I was in charge of strategic planning.
And at that time, GE was like
number three in the world.
Wow.
And Jack Welch, again, to become chairman,
wanted us to become
number one in the world.
That was his goal.
And to do that, I looked around,
took some calculations
of the various markets in the world,
and was very clear
that you had to get Japan.
And I looked around in Japan
and I found that Hewlett-Packard,
a company I had a lot of respect for,
already had a partner called Yokogawa.
A very famous group.
Yokogawa Hewlett Packard, YHP.
We became YGE.
Yokogawa General Electric.
And we, with Yokogawa,
we became number one
in the Japanese market
for a period of time.
Ahead of Toshiba.
Ahead of Hitachi, Shimadzu, etc. etc.
Didn't you go on to work for Toshiba later on?
Didn't you go on
to be a senior vice president
at Toshiba later on?
Yes, absolutely.
Very nice.
Well, they knew me.
They knew me very well.
Exactly.
But I'll tell you an interesting thing.
While I was fighting them in CT,
I was also their partner
in medical equipment
having to do with, what do they call it,
cardiac type systems.
So, we were already working with them
at that time.
So, but in CT, we were enemies.
So, I think it's interesting
how in these huge, huge companies
you could be collaborators
and partners on some fields
but then you have other market aspects
where you're complete competitors
and it's a natural thing, right?
By the way, it took a lot of trust.
I'm sure.
A lot of trust
and no one violated that trust.
Another thing that was very important
in those days to again become the leader
in the world market was
to get a position in China.
And I led a team to China,
and we won to get
the very first whole body scanner
into the China market in Beijing hospital.
1980.
And that was really exciting.
I cannot tell you
because everyone was there for that.
Everyone wanted it.
There were eight companies
and I was asked,
"Do you want to be first or last?"
I said, "I'll be last going in."
Wait, wait, wait. Paint me the picture.
There's eight companies,
pitching to this hospital?
Exactly.
Okay, I wanna hear this story.
Tell me this story again.
Well, there were eight
and we came in last.
As in literally you walked last
into the room to show your product.
Well, it was over a period of weeks.
Okay.
We came in to show them
what we could do.
Right.
And at the end of that, they said,
"We wanna go to contract."
Wow.
So, I sent my team home.
I worked in the embassy,
the US Embassy in Beijing.
Wow.
Worked up the contracts,
sent the contracts home.
And the team, that was by fax,
if you remember in those days
there was nothing else.
And the team looked at it
and they turned it down.
They turned down the deal.
And that's when I made
one of the biggest decisions
of my lifetime.
I said "I'm signing this deal anyway"
and I signed it subject to approval
by senior vice president,
Dr. Walter L Robb.
I then went home with the documents,
put it on the table,
and there was the whole senior team.
And Walt Robb looked at the document,
never even looked up
to the other guys at the table,
took the pen and signed.
Now, how did I know
that he would probably do that?
We did not communicate.
His boss was Jack Welch.
If Jack Welch found out
that he had in his hands
the opportunity to take China
and he turned it down,
that would not have been a good thing.
Unfortunately, by the way,
both Welch and Walt Robb
passed away over the last year.
Two spectacular people.
But I have to ask
Did you think through this
as you were sitting in the embassy
and you were wondering,
"Should I go alone in this battle?"
because the outcome could have been,
you come home,
you bring this to the table
and you could get fired.
And you get fired.
Yes.
You know what?
That would have been worthwhile.
because then I'd make a big deal
in that story.
That's for sure.
No, no, no.
It was obviously,
you got to always look at
no matter what little ...
What is the right thing to do?
And you have to understand the players
that you're working with,
that you report to.
And it was, that's why I'm saying
it was one of the most
incredible experiences.
On that plane home,
I was just so exhilarated about
what that scene was gonna be
when I came in here.
Why did they turn it down?
They turned it down because of the fact
that they are very conservative.
They worked for GE all their lives.
Taking on the China deal was a major risk.
People and large companies
don't take on large risks.
Right.
I'm a semiconductor guy.
I was only around for four to five years.
For me, this is the way we did things
in the semiconductor world.
Right.
Everything was a risk.
Anyway, that was just terrific.
I then ended up running
the X-ray business at GE.
And then an opportunity came up
in the area of MRI.
And a company called Diasonics
came after me.
Turns out the CEO,
a very close friend of mine
from years back in school,
asked me to run the MRI division
of Diasonics.
They already had X-ray systems
and they had ultrasound.
And that brought me to California.
And it brought me to another program,
by the way that CT scanner
I forgot to mention,
we did the final development at UCSF.
No, you studied
your bachelor somewhere else.
GE was in Milwaukee.
Okay.
However, we worked
with the main site at UCSF,
also a site in Milwaukee.
Okay.
But with Diasonics,
again, I came back to UCSF.
So, you could ... either way.
Yes.
And the research team
that we had was from UCSF.
Okay.
Dr. Leon Kauffman and his team
were a group within UCSF
that came and worked with us.
And who is my major competitor?
GE.
So, when you're at GE,
your biggest competitor was Toshiba.
When you're at Diasonics,
your biggest competitor is GE.
Yes.
And when you're in Toshiba,
who is your biggest competitor?
The world.
No. Again, it was GE.
Of course.
GE, Siemens and Philips.
And the beautiful thing about
the MRI business for us, is that,
I realized we're a small company.
If we're a small company, universities
are very expensive to work with.
So, we can only be very focused
on a few of them.
Then there's the hospital market.
They're much too conservative
to buy from us.
It was, we're a risk for them.
But then there's the private market.
We created the private market.
Those of private docs who feel
MRI is just what they want
and they wanted it for shoulders.
They wanted it for hips.
They didn't want to do brain work
like the universities would do.
Right.
And we went after the private market.
And that made us
second in the United States
only to General Electric.
Wow.
It was an incredible situation.
The other thing we did is
we sold them on a paper study basis.
We created that at that time.
So, instead of spending
two or three million dollars
for the whole system,
we put the system in.
We had a finance company
work with us on that.
But we made our bread
from the paper study.
Interesting.
What does that
mean paper study?
Oh for every study that they do,
they pay us.
Incredible. I love that model.
Yeah.
Well, today it's called subscription.
It's called all kinds of things.
Right.
But back in 1983,
it didn't exist except for us.
Wow.
The other thing that happened,
there's a place,
MD Anderson is a very famous center
by the way, located in Texas.
They wanted an MRI.
And we were working with a group
called Texas Medical Equipment.
Another, a player in the private market
who had a number of sites.
Our sites.
So, they put in our system into a building
near MD Anderson,
and we then supplied MD Anderson.
The other thing we did is we had vans.
We put a system in a van.
We drove that van around the community.
The docs in each of those sites
would have a workstation of ours
inside the hospital.
So, just picture this Michael.
Customer comes into the van.
The imagery is taken.
It's sent, streamed. A lot of streaming today.
We were streaming then 1984, 1985.
There was no Internet back then.
Streaming it inside the hospital.
And inside the hospital,
the doctor just went to the workstation,
which is next door to his office.
As far as he was concerned,
the system was in the hospital.
Incredible. Incredible.
It was really incredible.
Ron, we have just a few minutes left
and it's such a unique privilege
to be able to speak to somebody
who is really a pioneer
in all of these devices.
My girlfriend's father is a radiologist.
So, I'm getting exposed to all these
incredible devices and technology.
And all of a sudden I get to speak
to somebody who helped bring them
to market back in the day.
And I'd love to get your input.
What earned secrets
or what insight do you have
from your impressive career
over the last 35 years in this industry?
What can I take away
as a young entrepreneur
from your experiences?
Well the first thing is vision
and an example of a vision is,
when I saw the opportunity
to instead of having flat images,
have images in open 3D space
where the doctor can interact
with the object.
Just think about swimming
through your brain,
as opposed to being only able to see
a flat image of your brain.
It makes all the difference in the world.
Having that kind of a vision
got us into something
called "interactive mixed reality"
Now becoming a very big thing.
We've been at it
for five or six years already.
The other thing is
being a dot collector, a connector.
What is a dot connector?
Well, there's radiology, there's surgery
and realizing that radiology
and surgery need to come together.
So, when we showed them
this open 3D space imaging
and a radiologist said,
"Oh, with this I can speak intelligently
to a surgeon."
And then a surgeon said,
just a minute later,
"Wow.
I've never used a workstation before."
I said, "Why not?"
He said,
"I've never opened up a patient
and seen a 2D view."
Right.
Right? Everything's 3D in surgery.
Yeah.
So, our technology was the bridge
between radiology and surgery.
Wow.
We've given so many papers on that
and that's why we're leading
in that whole area.
And the last point, is being a coach.
Being a director coach, I think,
is my life from now on.
And I'm already involved
in a number of startups
which we utilized the technology
from the company Echo Pixel,
where they're looking things
in open 3D space.
One is scoliosis.
You have to use three dimensions
in scoliosis.
And the reason they have so many problems
is because they use two dimensional views.
And things like that.
Right.
So, those are the aspects
that I think are all very important:
vision,
being a dot connector,
and being a coach.
Ron, are those the three words
that you would choose also for yourself?
Of how you would describe yourself?
Oh absolutely.
I love it.
I'm always looking for dots.
So visionary, dot connector,
and the last one?
And the last one is coach.
The last one is coach.
Ron, I wanna take this opportunity
to thank you again for your generous time.
Inspiring to hear how you helped
lead this industry.
And I think it's just so much fun
that you got to work
with all these different companies
who ended up being competitors
to each other and the world.
Yet, you always came out on top.
So, I think that shows quite a bit about
the visionary, the dot connectedness,
and the coach that you bring with you.
Thank you very much.
I wanted to get to talk also
about you're very involved
with J-Ventures that we're both at
but we didn't get to that.
But definitely,
it's great to have you there
and I love learning from you all the time
through all the work we do there.
So, thank you again and have a great day.
Have a great day and stay healthy.
Thank you so much. You too.
Take care. Bye bye.